la red eléctrica de texas en el sur de
eeuu es independiente del resto del país
el estado sureño es el productor de gas
natural más grande a nivel nacional este
hidrocarburo junto al carbón son sus
fuentes principales para producir y
suministrar electricidad a casi 30
millones de habitantes que tiene el
estado con la ola invernal estos cortes
se deben a que muchos de los pozos de
gas natural se congelaron e
imposibilitaron la producción de
electricidad las turbinas de energía
eólica también se congelaron y las
plantas de energía nuclear presentaron
interrupciones este duro invierno por el
que atraviesa eeuu ha provocado estragos
dejando decenas de muertos para muchos
ha sido impactante ver que uno de los
estados más ricos experimenta tales
condiciones
texas rara vez tiene temperaturas tan
bajas ahora sus habitantes luchan para
hacerle frente a la falta de energía y
el intenso frío que ha alcanzado hasta
los menos 18 grados centígrados en el
termómetro millones de hogares quedaron
sin luz obligando a muchos a dormir con
la calefacción de los automóviles o en
hoteles las inusuales tormentas
invernales también provocaron cortes del
suministro de agua
desde hogares el frío no cesará en los
próximos días los tecs anos tendrán que
prepararse para una nueva era en la que
el clima seguirá siendo imprevisible